topics for today are first we will uh so
on on the last class we covered
evaluation metrics
and uh kind of like a continuation of
that today we will talk about some
practical tips for
applying machine learning in practice uh
especially if you want to
you know build a machine learning model
focused on a real world deployment
and with that we're going to finish up
all the topics
and we'll spend some time talking
about the final exam format what kind of
a
final exam structure you can expect uh
in the take home exam
and then we're going to begin our uh the
full course review uh
starting all the way from the beginning
giving you an overview of what we've
covered
uh in the course uh so far we'll be
as part of the course review we'll be
emphasizing more on topics that are more
relevant for
for the exam and we'll go over both the
topics that we covered in the lectures
and also
discussing related homework problems so
we haven't really had a chance to kind
of
go over the homework problems in the
lecture itself
so we'll be discussing some of the uh
homework problems that we've covered and
how they kind of
match up with what we've seen in the in
the lectures and how they relate to the
lectures and so on
so machine learning for uh production
so with uh the algorithms that we've so
far in the course we mostly studied
algorithms right so we've studied
different kinds of algorithms supervised
unsupervised
read smart reinforcement learning we've
looked at some theory
and ah in the last lecture we also saw
some
evaluation metrics if you're
planning to build a machine learning
model for some kind of a
say a real life product that you say
you're you're
building a product for let's say in your
company so you're working for a company
or you want to
start a new startup which uses some kind
of a machine learning model
the approach that you uh take towards
building
a real practical model is somewhat
different from
the kind of approach you would take for
let's say
building a new algorithm to be published
in a research paper right
and most of the uh probably the biggest
difference
between machine learning in
practice and machine learning and
research
in practice
versus research
the first thing that you would do if you
were to
deploy machine learning if you're
building a machine learning model for
deployment
is to start
collecting
a dev set
right so the first thing you would do
before deciding
you know which model you want to use it
may be logistic regression it may be you
know a neural network
what have you the first thing you want
to do is start collecting
a dev set by start collecting a dev set
what we mean is
start collecting data that your model is
going to encounter
when it is deployed in production let's
say you're building some kind of
for the sake of an example let's say
you're building some kind of
a phone based app that recognizes things
in in the pictures that you take right
the first thing you want to do is start
collecting pictures
from you know uh from our mobile phones
right and the reason you want to do it
is you want to have
your dev set distribution
match the production scenario
right and it's important that you start
with this step even before you start
thinking about what your training data
is you know
first define what your dev set is and
then work backwards from there
right and you you want to spend as much
time as possible
on collecting a dev set that matches the
real world distribution as closely as
possible
and by matching it as closely as
possible we mean that
you know if your target set of users
are let's say uh those who take pictures
on
phones as opposed to say tablets or even
better if you
if you know that your target set of
users initially are going to be iphone
users versus android users
then take pictures from the camera that
you're going to your app is going to be
used in
right and then spend time on labeling it
yourself right that gives you a real
good feel for how your data actually
looks and feels
right so as part of this collect data
preferably from the same devices
collected from the same devices that
your
model is going to get used and
label it right once you do this you get
your
validation set or a dev set the next
the next thing you want to do is to
define an evaluation metric
right so these two tasks of collecting a
data set
and defining some kind of an evaluation
metric
should be the first thing you do if you
are you know some kind of uh if
say you're you're you're the leader of
an ml group or you're a product manager
the first thing you want to do is define
what your dev set is
which should be a good representation of
who your users or or
how your users are going to use the
model and defining what
defining a metric on this and this
metric will capture what's what's
kind of important for you from this
product right and once you define this
data set
and evaluation metric you now
effectively kind of you know painted a
target for your team to go after
right these two are should always be the
first thing you define
and once you're you done this then
then you know comes the question of what
the training set is
right so your training set could could
come from anywhere
right if collecting data is inexpensive
then you probably want to collect as
much data as you can
that mimics the production scenario and
make that your training set
however that's usually very expensive
right especially
you know if you want to label your data
set that becomes really expensive
because you you probably want to use you
know your own time or you want to spend
money and use
you know crowdsourcing to label your
data and generally
labeling data can be very expensive
and which is why most of the time our
training data
usually comes from a distribution that
may or may not
match your dev set exactly
right if you're working with images
let's say you're building an image
classifier
you may want to use some kind of a
pre-trained model or use
a very famous data set called the
imagenet
for for you know creating your training
data right and that can be very
different from
the uh from the use case where your
model will eventually get used
right so um collect so the next thing
you want to do
is now collect your training data
right and while you are collecting your
training data it should be
as as close
as possible
to the dev set
and generally collecting the deficit you
know
as i said collecting more of the dev set
itself can be pretty expensive
and here you you generally end up using
some kind of an automated labeling
automated or noisy labeling
right and you may be surprised that
noisy labeling or automated labeling can
sometimes be extremely effective
and the the idea there is that you kind
of make up by
quantity what you lose by quality right
and in fact we've actually seen
um uh you know some examples of this in
the course already for example in your
homework one ps1 i think it was question
two
you know we looked at the case where you
have some training set where the noises
are
where the labels are noisy where the
labels are available say only for
positive
examples and uh the the uh
unlabeled examples can contain both
positive and negative right that's
that's uh
one that's one kind of uh
data set that you may get by automated
labeling where you label only the
points that you are very confident of
and leave everything else as you know
unlabeled
right and with that you can still build
models in a naive way and then apply
some kind of a correction
to get you know pretty good or decent
models
this question
that's a very good question so so the
question is when we were doing homework
uh or you know
covering rest of the material we spoke
of first starting with some data set
some given data set
and split that into a test validation
and train
right why not do the same here as well
the reason why you want to
think about it this way is because
the approach that we uh discussed
earlier of starting with some given data
set and splitting it into three
was quite common in in um
you know a few years ago or a few
decades ago when data was really scarce
right now we are kind of um in a
situation where
it's easy to collect data it's difficult
to label them but it's you know
generally
you know the availability of data is
quite abundant in a lot of use cases of
course there are
use cases where data availability itself
is low for example
in in healthcare when if you want data
about some rare disease of course you
know you're not going to have
a lot of examples there but for the most
part um especially if you want to build
some kind of a
commercializable product or you know but
then
it's it generally tends to be around you
know you know
images text you know media uh videos etc
and generally it's um it's quite easy to
get
lots of lots of data uh but labeling
them is still hard
right and in these in these scenarios um
you probably want to have your model
be tested against the kind of scenarios
it's going to be deployed against
and have your test set performance
reflect that
reality when you know when when you
actually put it in deployment
as opposed to take some data set that
you uh you know obtained from you know
somewhere
and get a sense of generalization
performance to that
distribution which could be very
different from where your model gets
used
right so if you want to if you want to
um if you're thinking of
deploying your model in a real-world use
case always
start from the way it is going to get
deployed and work backwards from there
if you want you may just scrape the lid
for google images and then
label it or somehow and is that even
legal to do
from some like these websites
yeah so so so the question is uh you
know what about using
using uh you know scrape the web for
images and do some kind of automated
labeling is that even legal uh of course
if you are you know if you're scraping
copyrighted images then you know you're
actually subject to the terms you know
that come with the license
of that you know of whoever owns the uh
owns the images
uh so yes so uh legality is definitely
open
open question and you should you know
answer that um
in this course we don't provide you
legal answers for such questions
but you know you absolutely need to you
know uh ask those questions
and and uh find out if you know the the
method
that you're following you know is it
legal or not absolutely you should you
should pay attention to that
and um in terms of crowdsourcing
it is strongly recommended that the dev
set
the labeling of the dev set be done with
as much care as possible preferably by
you and your team
and you could use crowdsourcing for
labeling
say your training data but you want to
be as careful as possible
for labeling your dev set definitely
yeah
yeah so um we saw some of the
some of the automated what could happen
under automated labeling with
ah in in ps1 q2
that's the positive only only
scenario and once you once you kind of
ah
done your labeling then you get into the
question of
how do we build how do we build a model
that
works well in production right your your
goal should always be
to build a model that works well in
production
right which is which which might seem
closely related to a model that works
well on your test set or model that
works well on your dev set
but that is still a proxy you should
always aim for building a model that
works well
in production right and the way you want
to
work towards improving your model
performance on production
is to ah let's say you you um
come up with some kind of um let's say
you decide to use
i don't know svms or you know logistic
regression doesn't matter what it is
right any time you you
fit the model and you want to measure
performance
you should always measure this breakdown
so first you have say
human level performance
right and this human level performance
even though it is inaccurate it is
sometimes
okay to think of this as a proxy for
irreducible error
of course this is this is inaccurate but
it serves as a good proxy
we do have models that work better than
humans in many examples
so in those kind of examples this may
not always work but for the most part
if you're starting about building some
kind of a model or some kind of
a machine learning model for you know a
specific product
that you're working on then
human level performance on the dev set
can work as a good proxy for irreducible
error
again it's just a proxy yes question
yeah so the question is what do we mean
by automated labeling do we mean by
using some uh some data set that's
already labeled is that
so what what we mean by this is uh
let's say you're you're trying to um
build a classifier for
uh let's say
you know the the the prototype typical
example let's say you want to build
a classifier given an image is there a
cat in that image right
and let's say you scrape the web you
know possibly that's illegal let's we'll
push that question apart and you've
collected a big data set
and in this data set now we want to
label this data set as those having cats
versus no cats
right and you want to have some kind of
an odd so so
first thing you do is collect a dev set
that's going to match your deployment
scenario right if if your use case for
your for your
say mobile phone app is through pictures
then take pictures
from let's say your phone take lots of
pictures and manually label those that
have cats or not
right and then comes the problem of
collecting training data
right your data can be images that you
scrape off the web which may be
completely unrelated may look
kind of different from pictures taken in
your in your phone
and now you want to do some kind of an
automated labeling
right and what does it mean here you
could perform automated labeling with
some simple rules
for example if the if the file name of
the image has the word cat then maybe it
has a cat
so you know label it you know
how have some initial noisy labeling
where you look at the file name
if it has the word cat in it label it as
positive if it does not label it as
negative
that's very noisy you know what you know
it probably works
okay in terms of its
degree of noise in it you probably want
to still perform some kind of a spot
check
to see you know collect some random
number of images from this label data
set and see what fraction of them were
labeled correctly with this automated
rule and maybe refine it a little
further
till it is you know probably you know
say 90 percent accurate or 95 percent
accuracy
machine learning yeah you could use a
simple model to do this automated
labeling but generally
this automated labeling will use some
kind of prior knowledge or domain
knowledge
to construct a rule based you know it's
it's generally a
rule based labeling at the automated
labeling stage
right so you want to break down the
performance into the following ah
following parts
and then you have
training performance
and when you are training once you
obtain this training data
you probably want to split it into
a an actual train set and
what you might call as a trained dev set
which is a fraction of your training set
which is distinct from
the dev set that you're in in with the
goal of the dev set is to mimic the
deployment scenario as well as possible
but your training data you probably
don't want to
uh over fit or use all your training
data for fitting the model as well
so within the training data that you
that you've labeled possibly with
automated labeling you still want to
hold out a fraction of this
and let us call it the trained dev set
right so
train dev performance
it is sometimes common to take a
fraction of your dev set
and include it in the trained dev set
and yeah measure the trained of
performance and then
measure the deficit performance
and this is the part that you manually
labeled
and manually collected
okay and finally
we can talk about the deployment
performance
and by deployment performance what what
i mean is
when you actually deploy the model
into production and real users start
using your model
you know what's the accuracy what's the
level of performance um
on on on the real world right
and previously we were generally talking
about you know
train error and test error or maybe
train error
dev error and test error but here when
you when you actually put things in
in or when you're working towards an
actual deployment you actually want to
measure all five you know
all you know there are these five
different measurements that you're uh
measuring and the way you want to think
of each of these different performance
is
the human level performance as i said
you can think of it as a proxy for
irreducible error
once you once your model starts working
really really well
it might start performing better than
humans but you know we will ignore those
cases for now and the gap between
training performance and human level
performance
the gap between these two you want to
think of this gap
as a proxy
to the bias in the model
right the gap between training
performance and human level performance
right and similarly the gap between the
trained of performance and the training
performance
you want to think of that as the
variance in the model
right
and now similarly the gap between the
train devs performance and the dev set
performance
this gap you can think of it as the
error
due to distribution mismatch
distribution mismatch between
dev and train
right and this distribution mismatch
is is because the training set that you
obtained
was up generally obtained from a
different process
rather than starting with uh rather than
the
the process you use to mimic the test
set because you know this is too
expensive
right and this is generally you know ah
therefore you can think of this as like
you know
due to cost of collecting
this question so the train dev
is a fraction of the training data that
you obtained that you hold out as
as you know a trained dev set
because we're calling this dev so we you
know just call it train dev because it
was
it's just a fraction of the training
data that you have which is distinct
from the dev set
which you manually collected and labeled
so the purpose of the drain dev set is
to kind of
use it as a way to check if your model
is over fitting or not
and the and the dev set is used
to check if the if the model is going to
work well
in the deployment scenario or not
because the training data that you
obtained
was distinct or different from the um
from the from the potential deployment
scenario
okay and finally
the gap between these between the dev
set performance and the deployment
performance
is generally due to over fitting on the
dev set
how can we over fit on the dev set even
though we are not training on it
we can over fit on the dev side because
we go through the the cycle
of refining our model and tuning our
model
to work better and better on the dev set
to reduce this gap
and in a way indirectly due to our hyper
parameters
we will inevitably end up over fitting
on the dev set
right and once you over fit on the dev
set then
your your actual deployment performance
can be pretty
pretty bad right and
to kind of summarize our goal is to
build models
that work well in deployment right this
is our eventual target
you should never lose track of the
eventual target which is deployment
performance
and all these other different
measurements that you perform are a way
so that
you can perform diagnosis to improve the
deployment performance
right these these performance by
themselves
are not of direct interest right you
want to use these
to diagnose where the error where the
error is coming from
and go after and fix that error so that
eventually we can do well on
on our deployment performance and
the dev set as you can see
can be subject to overfitting especially
if you evaluate your model performance
on the dev set multiple times
you're going to reach a state where you
kind of over fit on it in which case
you might want to go back and recollect
a new dive set because you you overfit
on on the
on the old one right and that's that's
pretty common too where you
you you recreate a new dev set because
you
overfit on the current one
and now
so given these lets lets ah
lets kind of go through some a simple
exercise
to see what steps we can take to
mitigate each of these
right let's say you measure the human
level performance and it's pretty low
what do we do
well if the human level performance is
pretty low like you we have not even
started
so there is no model in question here
you have collected it uh you know
a data set and then you ask a human to
to
measure the human's performance against
um
on that task and that is pretty low
yeah you know whatever metric that you
come up with accuracy or precision or
recall
get better humans
exactly so you know you you if the human
level performance is pretty low
then maybe go after a different problem
right so
because um it's you know um especially
if you want to
run some kind of diagnostics and and you
know uh
characterize your errors if the human
level performance is pretty low on a
task
then you know you can think of it as a
problem where the irreducible error
itself is very high
so it's kind of a bleak scenario it kind
of represents it says that the problem
is really really hard
right now what if you know the human
level performance is pretty good it's
it's it's
you know within an acceptable range but
your training performance is low
your training error is high right but
you know when
when when you asked a human to perform
the labeling or human to do the
prediction it was pretty good
you know what does this represent it
represents you know your model
probably has high bias right and what do
we do to address high bias
increase increase flexibility of the
model
right so
so steps to kind of overcome this
increase flexibility of the model and
how do we increase the
flexibility of the model
add features
add feature and somebody said add more
non-linearities
so let's call it add features or say add
more depth if you're adding a neural
network
add depth
right and i think someone said reduce
regularization
right and let's say if you're if you're
using some kind of a kernel method use
more complex kernels
right so these are these are these are
like a standard
standard approaches for fighting bias
if your model has high bias then these
steps will help you fight
um bias and if you remember
uh bias is due to
uh the inability for the model to
represent like the true function or
the best possible uh function the best
possible function of the best possible
model
will give you you know the irreducible
error
that's the best possible we can do and
the inability
of our hypothesis class to represent the
best possible model is called bias
and anything you can do to increase our
model class to make it a
an even bigger class will help fight
bias
right so all these things you know
adding more features
adding more depth adding more width in
your neural networks
reducing regularization because
regularization pushes your model towards
towards zero you know more complex
kernels all these are different ways
in which we can we can fight bias
now
what if the gap between the training
performance and the trained dev
performances
is more what can we do there
so what can we do here
everything opposite so yeah so look for
smaller models
right and fewer features
your features increase regularization
increase regularization you know less
complex
kernels
and finally there is one you know most
of these are like the
inverse of inverse of the other however
there is one thing that is distinct
which is
collect more data
right does getting more data help fight
bias
can it
some say yes some say no so generally
you don't think of getting more data
as for for fighting bias if your problem
is that your training performance is
much much worse compared to human level
performance it means that you the the
model that you have cannot even fit the
training data that you have
right which means the the the problem is
that the model class that you have
is too inflexible right getting more
training data
will not necessarily help your model fit
that
superset better than the subset that you
had initially right so
if your training error is low you kind
of think of it as a proxy for bias
and the thing you want to do is not
necessarily go and collect more data
but start increasing the capacity of
your model make it more flexible
however if the gap between the trained
error and the training performance
is large it means your model is doing
really well
in just fitting the training training
data right
but it's not able to generalize well
which means you want to probably make
your
make it harder for the model just to
just fit the training data so just
collect more data
right and with the hope that it
generalizes better
and what do we do if there is a gap
between train dev
and dev set
change the change the
rules for labeling
right so if if the gap between the
trained
and dev set is is high then
it's an indication that there's a
distribution mismatch between the
deficit and the training set
and when there's a a gap between the the
when there is a distribution mismatch
between the
the dev set and the train set then
obviously the
the thing that you want to do is
minimize that difference in
distributions
right one way to do it is to make the
devs at closer to the
training set which would not be ideal
which would be kind of
you know yeah it would be kind of
stupid in a way but instead what you
want to do is make your
train dev set be closer to your dev set
right and that you can do in in there
are many ways to go about doing that
for example you may want to you know
spend some more money and
and you know collect more real data
realistic data
label them and include them in your
train dev and training
set you could do that you could also
you know do something more clever for
example in your training set maybe
there's a subset of your training set
that's somewhat close to your
dev set maybe upward those examples
right
you could also you could also maybe
think of some kind of you know data
transformations on your training set for
example
if your dev set is mostly images that
are black and white but your
training set has lot of color images you
know maybe run some filters and make
them look
you know closer to your dev set in some
way
you this is this for this you need to
use your creativity
and somehow reduce the the distance
between your
training distribution or the train dev
distribution and the def set
distribution and you want to reduce it
by making this closer to the dev set not
the other way
this question
oh so just to clarify what i meant was
making this closer to your
training set by what i meant was replace
some of these examples by example from
your training set
right you you could potentially change
this
to make this closer to your training set
right but that would be kind of
against the points
yeah that was my point so you want to
keep your deficit as it is and not
change it
but you would want to incorporate
examples like as you observed
or something like that but you realize
like since
your training data was collected in a
very noisy way maybe
it has a lot of images
yes that was my point yes yeah that was
no that's not stupid yeah right
okay and what if the gap between the dev
set and the deployment performance
is poor let's say you you you know
you've taken your dev set in in as
as kind of a pure way as possible you've
sampled it randomly from
the actual deployment scenario you've
labeled it and
you you fit your model and it's working
well on your dev set but it's not
working well in real performance
in real life right what do we do then
yeah exactly so it's probably time to
refresh your dev set right it's it's
it's a good indication that you've
likely
over fit on your dev set by going
through this cycle over and over again
as as as we mentioned in one of the
earlier lectures the more number of
times
you measure the performance of your
model against a dev set
and tweak the model to improve the
performance think of that as your data
set getting rotted
right it probably means your dev set has
rotted quite a bit
and it's time to collect a new dev set
and and
and start all over again
and these two
that we saw were some of the things that
we saw earlier in the bias variance
lecture
right in order to improve your model
performance
there are a set of actions that you can
take
and that set of actions contain
contradictory actions right so some of
the action
me is to add more features whereas
another action is to
reduce features right these are all
actions
to improve your overall model
performance but in order to decide which
specific
action you want to take at the at this
moment
it is very critical that you look at
both the
training set error and your def set
error in order to characterize whether
the current problem that you have is a
high bias problem or a high variance
problem
right and only then one
only after you characterize whether the
immediate problem is a high bias problem
or a high variance problem
only then do you do you choose on the
subset of actions that are meaningful
and take that action
this question
make both bias and variance equal
yeah so so the question is do we stop
when you know this error vanishes and
this error vanishes
or our or the gap between them vanishes
and the gap between them vanishes which
means they're all three are equal
right so the question is do we stop then
the answer is no
your goal should always be deployment
performance right
and all these are components that you
can tackle with different action sets
to help reduce
[Music]
you want to tackle bias or variance in
your model
you have like the best you can hope to
do is reduce both of those
uh difference in performances to equal
that's the best you can do right
yeah so there is there is some amount of
um so uh
let let me get to that in in you know um
in a few minutes
um of of uh you know what what what you
um
what you want to do the short answer is
yes you know you can
you can you can always collect more data
and drive your variance towards zero and
you can always
increase a bigger you know make a use a
bigger model and drive your bias towards
zero
so theoretically if you have enough
compute and enough data you can drive
both bias and variance to zero
right that's one way to think of it this
question
so what do we do when training error is
large
but dev at the train dev or a dev error
is small
do you mean this gap is large and this
gap is small or the training errors
absolute value
is large but the train dev or the dev
errors absolute value
is better
so so again just to understand your
question better do you mean
that the gap between trained and trained
ever small or the train dev itself is
less than the training error
which of the two scenarios are you
talking about so are you talking about
the scenario where
the training performance has let's say
80 percent accuracy
and the train dev is 79 accurate which
means the gap is small
or are you talking about the case where
the train dev is 85
accuracy which means you know the the
performance is better than that which of
these two are talking about
the latter one eighty-five percent so
this generally means
uh that if the if the uh training
uh dev performance is higher than the
train uh performance
this generally means that there is still
some kind of
um that there's
still some kind of uh uh
distributional mismatch in the sense
that
maybe there is your trained devs set is
not
a perfectly randomly sampled from the
from the dev set maybe there are some
bias in the way
your you've sampled the train deficit
and it could be that the the fraction
that got left out in the training set
were harder examples but
you know this biased subset are easier
examples
it's something like that generally you
don't expect this to happen
so if this happens it probably means you
want to reshuffle your ex
your train uh you know merge them and
re-split them again
uh usually that's that's one way to go
about it because
you should not expect uh there's no
reasonable
uh uh reason for your train dev
performance to be better than the
training performance right
it means you're likely doing a bad job
at you know even just fitting your
fitting your training data or you know
there is some kind of a bias
in the way you split your train and
website
good question right
so now you know there are there are
um there are what we've seen is you know
there is some action space
and yes question how do you measure
deployment performance then because for
everything else you have
you know a set of data that you kind of
measure against but for
that's a very good question so how do we
measure deployment performance
and usually the way you measure
deployment performance is to
you know generally uh there might be
ways in which
the the feedback is implicit in in
deployment for example let's say
if the action that if if the prediction
that you made was right
let's say the user ends up taking a
certain path of actions
and you can you can kind of get this
implicit feedback of whether your
prediction was right or wrong uh so
sometimes you can you kind of get that
automated feedback
in other other scenarios you want to
make this prediction on on the real data
and then have somebody relabel them and
measure the performance
right so collect collect some
predictions that you made in deployment
and have somebody label them just to see
what fraction of them you got right
yeah yeah think of it as another dev set
if there is no implicit feedback
but sometimes that can be implicit
feedback in your overall application
let's say your the user takes a certain
kind of actions if the prediction was
right right and in that case you get
like automated
automated feedback good question so um
so here in our action space we saw that
some of these actions
can can can you know this this can be
kind of contradictory with other actions
for example add features versus fewer
features
add depth versus reduce depth reduce
regularization versus increase
regularization right so some of them are
kind of contradictory
and it's inevitable that you absolutely
need to do a bias variance analysis
to decide which of those actions you
need to take however
there is this this
this action called get more data right
so get more data
can help fight bias you don't expect it
to help
it can help fight variance but you don't
expect it to
you know affect your bias in any way but
generally getting more data
is a pretty expensive step and
quite often you know you need to answer
the question of
you know is it does does getting more
data is it going to help me or not
right is go getting more data is it
going to help me
fight the you know the variance in my
model or not maybe
you know the the amount of data that you
have is is
is not sufficient or maybe it is
sufficient how do you how do you answer
that question
so for that there is this you know
pretty useful plot
that you would want to make
so the ah the plot that you want to do
is something like this
so this think of it as
fraction of
data or data size
green line is desired
performance level or let's call it this
desired error level
and this axis is
error and this is a fraction of data
right and you have your
right so what we do is we take the
the full data that we have and split it
into smaller and smaller fractions right
and with each of the small fractions
each of the smaller fractions
get the train error and test error or
the
dev error from that fraction alone
and then take a bigger set get the
corresponding
train and error from the bigger fraction
then you know
get an even bigger set so each of these
here represents your data size
increasing
right so you you know for simplicity
assume both your
dev set and train set are proportionally
increasing
and with each with with with increasing
data size plot both the
train error so or train so this is the
training error
and this is the
test error
right in this scenario
the desired error level is is somewhere
over here
you know think of it as human level
performance and by
plotting your model performance of both
the train and test error
as you sub sample your data and a sub
sampling would go this way as you
as you um measured on the full data
this kind of a model where the train and
test performance come
really close will tell you that
collecting more data is not going to
help you right
because the gap between the training
error and test error
is pretty small and there you know
they're pretty
close to converging so if you were to
collect more data
and if you were to extrapolate these
they would probably
kind of you know convert
to this level right and the the the two
are pretty close to converging
right so this is a scenario where
collecting more data
is not going to help you right this is
think of this as a
high bias scenario
and for the question of collecting more
data
the answer is no
so collecting more data should not be
the first thing you are thinking of
in in um in such a scenario right
however
your in situations like this
where
this is your desired error level
and your training error
that's your training error let's see
i am loosely calling this test error but
you know think of this as your trained
have set or a dev set error
right and in this scenario
collecting more data so again this is
fraction of data
or data size
here it would be reasonable to you know
extrapolate this
as you know this rising up a little
further
and this coming down a little more
right so if your if your plot looks like
this
then you want to think of this as a high
variance scenario
say nor rio
and for the question of collect more
data
the answer here is yes you know it is
worth collecting more data it is
it is worth depending on you know um how
much you value
your performance it may be worth
spending more money and
you know collecting more data right
whereas if you are over here your
training
error itself is a lot worse than the
desired performance level
and your test error is matching your
training error
which means you probably want to
increase your model capacity right use a
bigger neural network or use more
features
or use a more complex kernel right so
that first you bring your training error
down and
you know
any any questions on these yes questions
yeah so so the question is how do we set
the desired error level
and and that is um there is no
common answer for that that really
depends on
your application and you know as as as
the you know owner of the product you
need to decide what your desired error
level is
you well so the desired error level
it may not always be possible to bring
it down to zero
and the value to which you want to bring
it to will actually depend on
you know the metric of your choice right
so so
if your metric is say accuracy and your
prevalence is very low then
you know this will be like a really low
value in general so it depends on your
choice of metric so intentionally i've
just
called it error but what the actual
you know units here are will depend on
the metric that you've chosen
any other questions
so the desired error level performance
uh
could be upper bounded by human level
performance sure it could be
all right any other questions
uh let's see are we done with the
practical
a few more concluding
comments as i said uh
always always always
our goal should be deployment
performance right don't lose sight of
the
end goal right all the other
measurements that we do
are only to aid us in taking the right
actions
so that the deployment performance
improves right
it's very common to lose track and just
focus on say devastate performance or
just focus on
the trained of performance but you
should never lose
you lose lose track of the fact that
your end goal
is always the deployment performance and
why while deployment performance is your
end goal it is
for for tactical purposes you want to
measure
the training performance and the trend
of performance or the training
performance and the dev set performance
and look at those and the reason you
want to measure them
is so that you can decide which action
to take right but the action you're
taking
is with the goal of still getting good
deployment performance
right and this is where bias variance
analysis kind of comes into picture
because with bias variance analysis you
can decide
among these conflicting set of actions
which is the action that you want to
take if you blindly take some action
that let's say you know um increasing
features
is a good thing and if you if you go go
ahead and increase your features
then um you know that may be wrong
or the wrong thing to do if the problem
that you're facing is high variance
uh similarly um let's say you're you're
at some uh you're getting some kind of a
model uh some kind of a performance on
your dev set
you know you you feel it is you know
insufficient
and you go about just collecting more
data to increase your deficit
performance
and if you are in a scenario like this
where your test set performance
was lower than than the training
performance which means that this set
error was higher than than the desired
level error then collecting more data is
not going to help you
right and and therefore
looking at the train error looking at
basically
the breakdown of the performance at all
these metrics
is extremely crucial to decide what the
next action that you're going to take is
is going to be
and another final advice is in your
homework
uh basically you've been
implementing a lot of these algorithms
implementing gradient descent yourself
implementing gda yourself or neural
networks yourself
please don't ever do that in in in in
in production right don't implement the
algorithms yourself always always use
some kind of
a software package that somebody has
already implemented and tested
you know don't go about doing gradient
descent by yourself if you want to build
some kind of a
real world application right that's
that's totally the wrong
thing to do it's it's very important to
implement neural networks yourself for
the purposes of understanding how they
work
right but but you know uh don't don't do
that
don't go about you know in some kind of
an adventurous path and implement
gradient descent yourself for your
application yes questions out there
biggest pitfalls in practical stuff what
do people do
so so so the question is you know uh
there you know a lot of people you know
probably you know know this knowledge
um but still lots of you know companies
fail lots of teams fail
why does that happen and i don't think
there's a single answer to that
because first of all you may know all
the theory but
you know your execution may be poor
right you know
even though you know things you may not
always execute them in the right way
that apart there can be you know other
reasons
beyond your you know control for example
even though your
machine learning approach was correct
you may be solving a wrong problem for
which there's no customer traction
right so there are lots of other reasons
that come into picture why teams fail
right it's not always
the the uh the technology that causes
failure
right so it's equally important that you
go after
a problem that you know that's kind of
worth solving and there are you know
people
or or you know something that's valuable
if solving the problem is valuable then
you know um it's it's it's uh
it's good but if your problem is solving
a problem even though you solve it well
if nobody's interested in the solution
then you know obviously you know
you're like the team is going to fail
not for machine learning reasons but
you know it's still a failure
all right ah any other questions on this
before we move on to
um topics related to the exam
cool okay so
so for the for the um so the next thing
i want to
briefly touch upon just for a few
minutes is to give you
you know some kind of an expectation of
the format of the final exam
[Music]
we have posted some some practice final
exams
on on pr job which hopefully you've
already had a look
um however use those
those those practice exams as
only for the purposes of you know
getting access to a pool of questions
right the format of the exam uh
this time will likely be uh different
and in terms of the format itself
ah there are going to be
so uh so the the the format that i'm
going to describe now
there is a very high probability that
that will be the format but there is a
small probability we may
you know tune a few things ah but
you know more or less what you can
expect is
the first question is going to be true
or false
and they're going to be about 10 of them
the second question is going to be short
answers
and they're going to be about five of
them
the third question is uh
you can call it a theory question i'm
just going to call it theory right
uh it's going to be basically just math
and
it's a it's a they're going to be sub
questions where essentially it is a much
longer proof
for which we kind of guide you by
breaking it down into you know
sub problems and you know you solve each
of the sub problems you will you would
have effectively
solved the full question and the fourth
one
is you know you can call it
theory slash application where again
um it's it's uh it's kind of
a new problem setting that you know it's
like
a novel scenario for which you want to
extend some of the the ideas that you've
learned in this course
to this new setting and they're going to
be like two
theoretical parts where you like kind of
derive whatever the update rules
prediction rules etc
and a third programming component
where you implement these rules in the
starter code that we provide and you
execute it and you get a plot and you
you know include the plot in your
write-up
so this is going to be the the structure
of the exam
you can i would say you know expect it
to be hard
it's not going to be long so you know
this is
you know not not not we don't have like
you know 10 big theory questions or
anything
it's much shorter than the homeworks
that you've encountered with
uh but it's going to be it's it would be
very necessary that you have a good kind
of
overall understanding of the course
you're
good at the prerequisites so things like
probability
right ah matrix calculus
linear algebra
and you know um general you know um
things that we've covered throughout the
course like maximum likelihood
etc it's very important that you have a
good understanding
of of the prerequisites
and also the important concepts on the
course like bias variance etc
but the the um the specific uh
the the you know the different set of
questions so basically these 15
questions and these two questions
you know kind of more or less touch upon
all parts of the course
any questions on the format itself
yes question the only coding will be in
the
one part yeah so the so the coding is
going to be the last part of of
uh question question four yes question
approximately how much hours
it takes 24 hours
uh it's hard to say so uh there are just
so these are you know true false
questions and short answers
um i mean we expect you to say true or
false in one sentence for
you know an explanation so one or two
sentences for justification similarly
short answers we expect you to you know
derive an answer
but you know we only expect you to
provide one or two sentences
you know of reasoning or justification
so if you know the answers
you know you can finish one and two in a
few minutes right but you know
if if you spend more time on this you
could potentially spend the entire 24
hours on just answering these so it's
very hard to tell
you know how long it's going to um take
so the format itself if you know
everything
we expect you to comfortably finish it
in three hours
but uh if you're spending time on on you
know
if you if you need more time to spend on
each of these you could potentially take
you know more than 24 hours so
it's hard for us to set an expectation
of how long it's going to take
for a student we could tell on average
but for a given student
you know the variance can be quite high
but you know um
think of this as like approximately two
homework questions
right and some you know this again you
know they're just true false and
short answers so it shouldn't take too
long
any any questions yes questions
very good question so during so this is
going to be a take-home exam which means
we're going to
post the the
post the exam on piazza as a pdf
and you will write up your solutions
you know in tech or by hand however just
the way you do your homework
preferably in tech so that it's easier
for us to grade
and you will post it on great scope like
any other homework
during the exam period itself we will
disable piazza
right so even though the format is like
a homework
it is not a homework it's an exam which
means
we will um
you cannot talk to each other uh you
cannot collaborate that's against the
the honor code
collaborating on the exam is against the
honor code
you can use any of the resources that
you want look at the course notes
look up you know watch the lectures
again look at
homework solutions you're even free to
look up the internet but you cannot post
on some
say stack exchange and ask for you know
somebody for help
but you're totally allowed to you know
search the internet for any
any uh kind of um
any kind of uh questions that you may
have uh
but no communication basically by
communication i mean
no asking questions uh but you can ask
google but you know
no asking um any other any other
human being right during the exam
um we will not
help you in piazza for things that you
don't
understand you you can create private
piazza posts
and if we think the question is already
clear about it we will not respond to it
just like an exam room uh you know if
you if you have a question
um you know ask yourself would this be a
question that i ask
a ta in an exam room and
you know create a private pr post if we
think it's a
valid question and if there is an
ambiguity then we will make a public
post
and clarify to everyone
however if we think that you know the
the the
um the the question is already clear
about it
and you have not thought uh sufficiently
about it then
we will refrain from answering those
kind of questions
or maybe we will tell you you know the
questions already
clear about it you know something like
that just so that
all the students obtain the same level
of of uh
response from us does that does that
answer the question
okay next question uh would you say that
fiat would be disabled um
will the uh like responses and questions
from throughout the like
before the exam throughout the quarter
would still be available yes you can you
can
um you you can open piazza and search
for all the previous
uh questions but uh i think there is an
option
in which we can disable posting new
questions or there's there's some such
feature in piazza
um that that we will be uh
this question
yeah so i i would say for for the math
part of it
uh focus on matrix calculus focus on
probability
and of course linear algebra you know if
you're really comfortable with them
uh we expect the
these parts to be pretty pretty
straightforward
yes
i'm sorry i didn't get the question
also the grades uh i don't remember it
offhand but it's
something like 10 10 and
i don't know it's like 15 15 or 10 10 or
20 20 something like that
all right so with that let's
kind of rewind all the way back and
start our course review
so the course review that we'll be doing
some amount today and the rest on
wednesday
is to is to kind of ah
provide an overview or a second look at
all the ah
all the topics that we have covered and
also kind of ah spend some time
spend some time drawing reference to the
relevant homework questions that you
answered
because a lot of a lot of the things
that you learned from this course
were from you know lectures but an even
bigger chunk was from the homeworks
right and and
uh some of you have probably
uh gotten all the homework answers
correctly and have understood
them well some of you may have gotten
the answers to their homework questions
but haven't really kind of
you know kind of kind of understood like
the big take-home messages from each
homework
the homeworks are a huge part of the you
know
of the overall educational aspects of
this course right and unlike you know
many of the other math courses where
homeworks are just assigned from
you know some random textbooks say
problem numbers you know 17 15 and 30 or
whatever
uh in this course a lot of effort has
been put into designing each homework so
that it kind of complements your
complements the lectures and the overall
learning experience so we will
at least do a quick quick reference to
each of the relevant homeworks and and
um at least touch up on the take home
messages from each homework as well
uh depending on the uh in the on the
order in which we are doing the review
right so let us jump right in we are
going to start off with
supervised learning that was the first
first section of the course
so in supervised learning if you
remember the goal in supervised learning
is to learn a mapping from x to y
where you think of x as an input
and y as an output and you are given
pairs of x y's as a training set
right so in supervised learning
so in supervised learning our goal is to
learn a mapping from
x to y and
in order to learn this mapping we have
provided a training set
s and that training set is basically
pairs of
x y examples
i equals 1 to n generally small n refers
to the number of examples in our
training set
right and x i
generally resides in a d dimensional
space
and this is usually called the input
and output output
y i if it resides
if it is a real value then we call this
regression
right if y i
is either 0 or 1 we call this
binary classification
right y i could be
you know um integers 1 2
3 and so on and this you can either call
it count
or poisson regression
and so on right and the overall
workflow for supervised learning was to
start with
a training set
training set and then run this training
set
through a learning algorithm
and the output of the learning algorithm
was a model which we call the hypothesis
right so think of this as your training
set could be
you know x y pairs where y is in zero
and one
the learning algorithm was uh say
logistic regression
and the learned hypothesis is the is the
set of parameters that you got when
logistic regression
reached convergence right and this
learned hypothesis will now accept
new examples x that it has not seen
before
from the training set and make
predictions
why right this is the
this is the kind of ah
workflow overview of what example what
happens in supervised learning
right and the first learn algorithm that
we learnt was linear regression
linear regression right in linear
regression
we we assumed that
the function h belongs to
this parametric family where we defined
it as
h theta of x equals theta transpose
x where theta was some vector
in rd and there's also this
intercept term we assume that x will
include the intercept term
and and you know theta will also the the
the parameter in the theta vector that
corresponds to the intercept term will
be the bias term
right so sometimes ah to make it
explicit we call it
d plus one and you know other times we
just leave it as theta d
and assume that you know its in there
and
in order to learn this
learn this parameter vector theta right
we need to have a learning algorithm
and the learning for the learning
algorithm we first define
what is called as a as a cost function j
theta
which is equal to sum over i equals one
to n
h theta of x minus
x i minus y i
square right and this is
also commonly called the squared error
where the
we want to penalize the the ah
the difference between the predicted
value and the correct value
and we want to penalize the square of
that value and sum over
all the squares of these errors right
and this we treat it as a function of
theta
and we want to minimize this error by
adjusting theta to the best possible to
the best possible value
right another way to write this in
vectorized notation
is x theta
minus y square
this question so is this the choice for
the call function because
of the gaussian or the the negative log
likelihood
or is this the other other choices
yeah so the question is is this cost
function a consequence of the
uh of assuming uh a gaussian
on the uh gaussian on the error term or
you know can you use other um other
other other loss functions
so there are um i'll be answering that
shortly
the the the quick answer is that you can
give this
a probabilistic interpretation that had
you assumed
a gaussian error term then this would be
the cost to minimize
but there are other interpretations for
linear regressions as well yeah
right so we
we what we want to do is find theta is
equal to
r min theta of j of theta
right and in order to to um
we put hats on all estimated values
and in order to perform this
minimization
first algorithm that we saw was gradient
descent
and in gradient descent we start with a
random initialization of theta
and run this iterative loop
where we repeat
theta equals
theta plus some learning rate alpha
times y i
minus h theta of
x i times
x i and here
we include a summation
plus alpha times summation
i equals 1 to n so this is
gradient descent and we also saw a
variant of gradient descent
called stochastic gradient descent where
instead of this
summation in each iteration we randomly
sample
some example sgd
where we repeat
theta equals theta plus
alpha times let's call it y
y y k minus
h theta of x k
times x k where k
sampled from the uniform distribution
between 0 and n or 1 and n
u right so sample
a random example number use that example
to run gradient descent for that
iteration right so that was stochastic
gradient descent
so this was one way in which you know ah
we solved
linear regression using gradient descent
and then we saw these few other
interpretations
of linear regression
okay
so this was this was using gradient
based approaches
where the gradient descent based
approach works for
any cost function not just linear
regression but in case of linear
regression
we can also get the closed form solution
for the final theta hat
directly right the second approach was
what we called as
normal equations for getting a closed
form solution
right and in the normal equations
we basically get x transpose x theta
equals x transpose y
from which if we assume
invertibility of x transpose x which for
now we will assume x transpose x is
invertible
we get theta equals x transpose
x inverse x transpose y
or theta hat equals x transpose x
inverse
x transpose y right and this is kind of
a pattern that you should tune your eye
to look for
because this pattern we also saw that
you know can can
show up in other places like you know in
fact analysis and factor analysis we saw
that
you know one of the parameter updates
looked very close to linear regression
right
so that's that's the normal equation
and then we saw a few more
interpretations of
linear regression so
the other one was projection based right
projection so if if um
so let us assume this is theta one
theta d and this is the parameter space
right and then there is this design
matrix x
right this is the matrix
and run it through this and we get an
output space
this is y one
y two call this y n
right so each dimension in the input in
the parameter space or the input space
corresponds to each parameter or each
feature and
each axis or each dimension in the
output space
represents a different example right
that is because x
takes input you know x is in
r d or sorry r n by d
so it takes as input something in d
dimension and produces output
something in the in n dimension right
and here because
this is a d dimensional space getting
kind of up
map to an n dimensional space where we
expect d to be smaller than n
the the column space or the range of
x is going to be a subspace of the
entire output space y
where the subspace has dimension d right
so
let me use some different colors
so um the entire d dimensional space
will now get mapped to some subspace
right and this subspace basically spans
to
infinity in all four directions and it
crosses through the origin by definition
a subspace crosses through the origin
right and this subspace is d dimensional
however for the given data that we have
the point y or the vector y may reside
outside the subspace
right so this is the y
that that is that is given in the data
so we are given
x and we want to find the theta
such that x x theta equals y
and x and y come from the training set
and we want to find
the best possible theta y such that x
theta is as close to
to y as possible
now the way we uh we cannot always solve
this exactly
right x theta will cannot always be
exactly equal to y because
y can reside outside the outside the
range of
of x so instead what we do is solve
x theta equals projection
of y onto the range of x
right instead what we do is project y
onto the onto the subspace
spanned by x and then solve
x theta equals projection right this
cannot be equal because y can
can be outside the range but this by
definition
the projection of of y onto the column
space of x
can be solved right
and if you remember the
projection of y onto the ah
a column space of x is given by
x x transpose x
inverse x transpose
y where this part is called the
projection matrix
right so this is this is just the
projection of y
on to the column space of x and once we
have it in this form
when y is projected onto the column
space it is now par you know
x this x can be inverted
in principle because there is a
bijection between the
input space and this column space there
is a one to one
bijection which means
we can now informally speaking
invert x form this projection ah for x
so you can cancel the x's and say x
transpose
x inverse x transpose
y right so this was the projection
interpretation of
linear regression and finally we also
went over the probabilistic
interpretation of
linear regression
so in the probabilistic interpretation
we know that that x theta will never
exactly equal to y with this linear form
so we say so instead we assume y equals
x transpose theta or theta transpose x
plus
sum epsilon where epsilon
is distributed according to a standard
normal distribution
with mean 0 and the
the the variance for now let us just
assume
sigma square which is some unknown
constant
right and now we can we can ah
write this as the probability of
so with this we can write epsilon equals
y minus x transpose theta or theta
transpose x
which gives us probability of epsilon
equal to probability of y minus
x transpose theta which is now a
gaussian distribution
should be 1 over square root
2 pi sigma square where sigma square is
inside the square root
times exponent
minus this has mean 0
so it would be this minus 0 square
which is just y minus x transpose theta
square divided by 2 sigma square
right so this is just the standard
normal distribution
and now if we perform maximum likelihood
that is basically find the parameter
theta
that maximizes this likelihood term
so that it is you know it conforms to a
standard normal distribution as much as
possible
we get l of theta is equal to
log product i equals 1 to n
1 over square root 2 pi sigma square
exponent of minus y
i minus x i
transpose theta square
over 2 sigma square
right and now
we can take the log of the product the
sum of the logs
so this gives us some i equals
1 to n log of this term is
some constant and it's the same constant
for all examples
so let us just call it you know some c
plus log and the exponent cancel
minus y i
minus x i transpose theta
square over 2 sigma square
right so we have some arbitrary constant
that is common for all examples and
another arbitrary scaling constant
that is common for all examples so
instead we can now write this as
you know some some other constant say c
prime
plus 1 over 2
sigma square times
the negative sum over i equals 1 to n
y i minus
x i transpose theta square
and now if you want to maximize
the likelihood objective so let me take
the
negative sign out over here
if you want to maximize this that is the
same as
minimizing the term inside right because
of the negative sign and we can also
ignore this two sigma square because it
is just a common
positive scalar across all examples
so r max
with respect to theta l of theta is
equal to
r min of theta of this sum over
i equals one to n x i minus
sorry
y i minus x i
transpose theta square
right so it's not by the the the reason
why we
cancel the two sigma square is because
we are only interested in the argument
and not the minimum value but just the
the theta value that gets us to the
minimum
right and and the theta value is is the
same whether we include the scaling
constant or not
and this is the probabilistic
interpretation of
of linear regression
probabilistic interpretation
right and here we saw basically the
gaussian distribution
and the main ah take away from this is
that
whenever there is a gaussian
distribution
involved there will always
that generally always corresponds to
some kind of a squared error
right because you take the log
likelihood the log will cancel
will this is a log of some constant log
and the exponent cancel
so maximizing the gaussian likelihood is
generally equivalent to minimizing
the squared error of some term
so that was ah linear regression any any
questions on the
on linear regression all good
and then after covering
linear regression we moved on to the
first
classification algorithm binary
classification algorithm
which is logistic regression
so in logistic regression we are given
logistic regression
why i is now either 0
or 1 right and in
order to solve logistic regression we
kind of follow the
probabilistic interpretation and do the
same thing for
logistic regression in logistic
regression we assume
that y i is sampled from a bernoulli
distribution
right bernoulli distribution and
probability of y i
equals 1 is given by this
1 over 1 plus e to the
minus theta transpose x
right and initially we
we kind of construct this 1 over 1 plus
e to the minus
function you know
as as a good reasonable guess which we
later
rederive in glms ah as a natural
consequence of assuming bernoulli
but for now let us just go ahead
where the predicted y i equals 1 so this
will be our prediction
and this gives us the likelihood
expression
so l of theta is now equal to 1
um log of the product
of i equals 1 to n of the
bernoulli likelihood which is y
i or sorry y hat
to the power
y i y hat
i to the power y i
times 1 minus y
hat i to the power
1 minus y i
where y hat i
is this and all of this is a function of
theta and this allows us to write the
the
objective of of logistic regression as
so log of the product is the sum of the
logs i equals 1 to n
y i log
y hat i plus 1 minus
y i
log 1 minus y
hat i right and for in in place of y hat
i
include this
as y i here and here and
to solve it we use gradient ascent there
is no closed form solution for this
right run gradient ascend and when you
converge with gradient ascent
the theta value is basically the
maximizer of this likelihood function
right that was logistic regression
any questions on that
can i repeat the last part so ah there
is no closed form solution
for recovering theta from this from this
likelihood expression
instead what we do is run gradient
ascent and run gradient ascend
till the algorithm converges and when it
converges
the theta value at the point of
convergence is going to be the solution
for maximizing the log likelihood of
theta
there was another question yeah
uh can you can you uh describe that a
little more i don't think i quite
i thought the probability that y i equal
to one is just
because y i is finally distributed
yes the probability that y i equals 1
is just v yes but the probability that y
i equals 0 is
1 minus v
third line is this one yeah so you go to
the probability of y i is equal to 1
my first question should that be y hat
so this is the probability that y y y i
equals 1
so this is just y hat this will be y hat
if y hat is
i see so so so the question is uh um if
i understood right
so here we are only talking about values
in order to make a decision
of what our predicted y i is should
there be a threshold to say
if this is greater than whatever 0.5
then the
um then the prediction is is is one
versus the other
and the the answer to that is logistic
regression so that's a good question
so logistic regression even though we
call it a classifier
it is actually just a probability
machine it outputs probabilities
and the way we convert these
probabilistic outputs
into decisions is using some kind of an
additional threshold after
the fact right so first we train a model
to just output probabilities
and then using you know
basically we saw this in the in the
evaluation metrics lecture
you know you can choose different
thresholds to
optimize for different kinds of metrics
so you can choose a threshold for
maximizing your accuracy or maximizing
your
you know precision or or what have you
right so that's that's generally done
after the fact of choosing a threshold
right but logistic regression by itself
just gives you probabilities
right next question
as the probability of
y i is given by this and then we want to
find
a good factor to approximate that's
correct so what we are assuming
is that the probability of y i given x i
can be represented in this form and that
there is some theta that gives us the
right answer
and we go about and and try to recover
recover that theta
and the the important thing to note
there is that it is an assumption
we assume that probability of y i equals
one can be represented
in this form and try to recover it and
in one of the examples that we saw
in i think it was homework two question
one 1
so in homework 2 question 1
we had this logistic regression
stability problem
right where you were given two data sets
on one data set logistic regression
would converge
and on another data set logistic
regression would would never converge
it would go on and on in that example
right the data was perfectly separable
which means
which means we could draw a line that
perfectly separated the two
the two classes and in in this kind of a
scenario
the assumption that
p of y equals 1 equals 1 over
1 plus exponent minus theta transpose
x the assumption that p of y given
1 so this should be given x right so
we assume a conditioning over there as
well so
correct it right over here
this is p of y given 1
given x
so the probability y equals 1 given x
can be represented
in this form in a way this assumption is
not met here
right because if you try to solve this
then
the algorithm never converges and theta
just goes to infinity
right so this this this this assumption
that ah
that the probabilities can be
represented from is an assumption which
may or may not hold
and in case of the perfectly separable
case this assumption does not hold
and in those cases ah to handle such
cases we want to use regularization
where regularization makes it kind of a
well-defined problem
and and we'll come to we'll review
regularization again when we go to uh
um
it passes through some of the points and
the point is so close together through
dimensional space that looks like
you know it may not be passing through
may not be separating perfectly
but there's something about separating
hyperplane in a higher dimension
you know in a higher dimension so can
you explain in which step of the
algorithm
the points are visualized by the
parameters as existing in two different
planes
so in the in the uh in the data set that
you have
that was given the the mod the data set
where the model does not converge
in in you don't have to map it to higher
dimension space
the separating hyper plane can clearly
separate them some of the points may be
so
close that in the in the graph they may
look as though they are
they are not separated because in in the
plot
each point is kind of represented by a
small circle and the circle may cross
the separating line and the line also
has some thickness
as as a consequence of just plotting it
but if you look at the
at the numerical values of each of the
points they are perfectly separable
yeah so you don't have to take it to a
higher dimensional higher dimensional
space for that example it's just that
the
the uh the plotting involves you know
thick lines and so it does not appear to
be
perfectly separated or they are too
close by but if you inspect the
numerical values it's it is perfectly
separable
so that was a logistic regression right
yes
you know trail off the values for the
alpha i think to
keep dividing it make it proportional to
one over t square at least iteration
so some people said that theoretically
it shouldn't converge but when you
implement it
can you provide some guidance yeah good
question so so in
in that question one of the one of the
uh sub
questions was to recommend ways to fix
this scenario and
one of the proposed ways was to make the
learning rate of uh logistic regression
decay over time at the rate of whatever
one over
t or t square or whatever so in in
[Music]
in that scenario it is kind of important
to
distinguish between convergence and code
versus
you know convergence mathematically
right so
if you were to decay the learning rate
and if you just decay to zero then
obviously the code will
will stop iterating
right but the the the parameter value
that you get
is not necessarily the argument or the
true argument
right why not actually i don't think i
caught your p or y given x
explanation so uh what what what i
mean by that is um so we define this l
theta
equals you know some some expression
right
and now in order to minimize this we
have this iterative algorithm
where we say you know repeat until con
repeat
we have some condition repeat you know
until some condition
and you do theta equals theta plus
alpha times y i minus h theta of x
i times x i right so we are we are
looping this now if this is perfectly
minimizable which means
if your loss function
is well defined and has a well defined
local minimum then this algorithm will
eventually
reach you know some some nearby point
here
and theta hat will be this this nearby
point
of the of the global minimum however
in in the in the problem that we had so
if this is theta
then the loss function actually looks
like this
right it reaches the minimum at infinity
right so now the question is if we run
gradient descent on this
the algorithm will keep you know hopping
over and over and over and over and over
with each iteration it keeps updating
theta
all the way to infinity now the question
is what do we mean by convergence
right by convergence you know the
mathematical meaning of convergence
means recover the true theta and in this
case there is no
true finite theta for it to recover so
it is not even
something that can possibly converge
right it just goes to infinity
now however here if we have a condition
you know some arbitrary condition which
evaluates to false
right this computational algorithm
will break out of the loop now do we
want to call that convergence
or do we want to call you know this
mathematical notion of convergence where
our estimate has has gone arbitrary
close to the true value
right so there are these these you can
you can um there are these two different
meanings of convergence one is you know
does this
computational algorithm stop
versus has our parameter
estimate come sufficiently close to the
true parameter
right there are two different two
different meanings
right so by adding regularization we
convert this ill frame problem
into a well frame problem right so
regularization
takes us from here to here
right so that was logistic regression
next we studied a second algorithm for
optimization called newton's method
right so newton's method is a root
finding method
where given some function f
now let us call this x
given some function f
and some random initialization right
newton's method takes us to the
nearest root what do we mean by root
root is an input to f such that f of x
equals zero
right so newton's method is a way where
with some random initialization
newton's method will take us to the
nearest root of a function
right and we use newton's method
for solving our cost function
by feeding the gradient of our function
as as the input to newton's method as f
so we set f is equal to
l prime right so the gradient function
is used as the function whose root we
are trying to
calculate using newton's method and
newton's method basically
gives us the update rule that theta
equals theta
plus 1 over
in this case um l double prime theta
times l of theta if
theta is scalar and in case
of the vector valued inputs
there is the extension of newton's
method called newton-raphson method
newton raphson where the update rule is
theta equals theta plus
1 or
h inverse of theta
times radian of theta
where h is the hessian h of theta
equals
h is the hessian and this is the update
rule
so a few things to keep in mind is that
newton's method
is not a cost minimizing method it is
not a cost maximizing method
it's just a root finding method which
means
no matter what kind of a function you
feed it you know it's plug and play you
don't ask newton's method to maximize it
or minimize it it's doing neither it's
just finding
the nearest root now if the function
if l uh that you're using in in
sorry if if l that you are
using in newton's method is a concave
function
i'm sorry a convex function right
so the if this is l
then l prime of theta
is going to be so so ah the gradient
starts out to be
negative here it becomes 0 over here
and it becomes positive later so the
grid the the gradient function
is an increasing function right so this
is 0
and this is l prime theta so it's an
increasing function
right similarly if your
l theta is concave right
then l prime of theta is
a decreasing function right and newton's
method
will just recover the point where
the gradient is zero right uh because
that that's what it's it's doing root
finding
it's not it is not checking whether at
this point
the gradient is decreasing or increasing
it doesn't care it just gets you to the
nearest root
which means if you feed in a convex
function or a concave function
it will automatically recover the
corresponding optimum point or the
stationary point
which also means if you feed a function
that is
you know kind of weird shaped where it
does not have a well defined
local maximum or minimum or has multiple
local maxima
it just takes you to the nearest
stationary point
what that means is if you start over
here
right if you if your starting point is
here then newton's method
will maximize and take you to the
nearest station
if you start over here or if you start
over here
then newton's method will take you will
minimize it and take you to the nearest
stationary point
depending on the initialization it was
either a local maximization or a local
minimization
right newton's method only takes you to
the nearest stationary point this
question
so generally you don't want to use even
use newton's method in these uh
unless you know that the function is
convex or concave
but i mean that itself is a very hard
thing to do
well so generally you know that by
function you by looking at the
functional form you can tell whether
it's convex or concave
like if you can show that the hessian is
positive positive definite
then you know it's a concave function or
a convex function and you know newton's
method is a good idea to use in those
cases if you're not sure
like for example in a neural network you
would never use newton's method on a
neural network
because it might might even be you know
maximizing to a local minima for a local
maxima for you
but if you wanted to then it should be
positive
yeah if it is if it is convex then the
hessian will be positive definite if
it's negative here
all right so looks like we've run over
time apologies for that we will continue
our our review in the in the next
lecture on wednesday and that will be
the
final lecture right thanks everyone
you